leader mitch mcconnell spent some time
in the oval office today with
congressional leadership and an attempt
to find some common ground with
president biden the minority leader of
the senate
mcconnell joins us now to discuss
senator thanks for
coming back to special report yeah glad
to be with you brett
tell us about that meeting how do you
describe it what would you take from me
well no staff in there just the six of
us the vice president was there we had a
very cordial meeting for about an hour
and a half
and discussed an issue upon which
there's a great chance
we could get a bipartisan outcome and
that's infrastructure
i did make clear to the president that
we're not
willing to go back and raise taxes that
is undo
the 2017 comprehensive tax reform bill
which brought us the best economy in in
a long time
as a february 2020 i think they know
that
that seemed to me to be accepted
so we need to discuss how big a bill
and how we're going to pay for it but
not not by raising taxes so did you lay
a market down i mean are you up to 800
billion now
well i don't know where will i think the
amount
ought to be defined by the scope and we
may have some differences about
how you define infrastructure i mean we
think through
tradition uh traditional infrastructure
roads bridges ports water lines
broadband are things we can agree on
to the extent that they start getting
off in rather exotic
definitions of what amounts to
infrastructure we could have a problem
but i think the takeaway from the
meeting brett is that
i think both sides would like to get an
outcome right well you had some of your
members
go up and try to negotiate on the
coveted stimulus early on and they came
away
saying it was a good meeting but then
nothing transpired i mean do you feel
like this is a different
effort after that oval office meeting i
do i think
i think they want a deal this time and i
think they want a deal
with us because i don't think they think
they can pass
this second effort through a
reconciliation package in other words i
don't think they can get
their own ducks in a row and so they're
coming to us
and that's generally how you reach
bipartisan agreements plus the subject
matter
is pretty popular on both sides of the
aisle yeah
so you'd agree to a separate package
maybe that meets your requirements
knowing that democrats would use or try
to
reconciliation for the other parts of
the spending and the family plan that
they've talked about
well they're in the majority they don't
need my permission
to decide how they want to pursue
something but we talked today about a
bipartisan
infrastructure plan that would require
our involvement in negotiation
i think we've got a good chance of
getting there on that issue whether
they'll try another reconciliation on
some other subject
is really up to them all right uh rare
to have the senate majority leader and
minority leader in a markup at a
committee hearing but this is over
s1 take a listen all across the country
republicans no longer want to let the
voters pick their politicians
they want to let politicians pick their
voters
deliberately targeting all the ways that
younger poorer and
non-white americans typically access
the ballot you fought back against that
in that hearing
where does this stand and what's your
take on the democrats
pitch what the democratic leader just
said is utter nonsense
what their bill is about is a partisan
takeover of how we conduct
elections in this country it passed on a
totally
partisan basis in the house the last
time we passed a major election
reform bill 20 years ago
chris dodd and i did it it was passed
with 90 votes
so this has nothing whatsoever to do
with anything other than a democratic
takeover let me give an example
number one they would take the federal
election commission which is currently
three to three to provide
neither side from taking advantage of
the other and turn it into three
to two with the president getting to
appoint
the tiebreaker so the democrats would be
in charge
of enforcing the rules terrible
terrible idea nothing bipartisan
about that secondly they want to take
public money public money and provide it
to politicians
to run their campaigns so that public
money is used to pay for attack ads and
buttons and bumper stickers and actually
whether individual voters support the
candidate or not their tax dollars
would be going to support them so you're
saying it's not going anywhere
no it's not going anywhere and there's
nothing uh
look it's a solution in search of a
problem we had rapid
incredible turnout last year
dramatically up
the highest turnout since 1900
a dramatically higher turnout than just
four years ago
nobody's votes are being suppressed
anywhere across america in any of the
states
this is a bill that should not pass
because it is a partisan takeover let me
tell you one other thing they do
before i lose my time here they make it
almost impossible to have photo id at
the polls
that people are overwhelmingly in favor
of the simple act of identifying who you
are
before you vote but you're you're
arguing against it very
vigorously but you don't think it has a
chance
no it's not going to pass the senate
there's not a single republican for it
senator manchin senator senem have made
it clear they're not going to
get rid of the legislative filibuster it
would take 60 votes to pass this bill
it will not pass all right i want to ask
you about a couple more things the
president says
he does not believe that unemployment
benefits and the extension of them
are affecting the jobs numbers we just
got word that the colonial pipeline
is uh turned back on now and the gas
shortages
and uh the run on gas and these stations
uh may come to an end soon
where do you see the state of the
country right now from your
vantage point as senate minority leader
i had a lot of meetings last week with
businesses of all sizes including people
running
hospitals the single biggest complaint
they had is they can't get people to
come back to work and
brett i know you've reported on your
network that a number of states are
saying to the federal government we
don't want your
plus up on top of unemployment insurance
any longer
because it's clearly a drag on getting
people to come back to work it makes
sense if you're making more money
staying at home
you'll choose just to stay at home
secondly
larry summers the treasury secretary
under bill clinton
and president obama's head of the
council of economic advisers predicted
back in january rampant inflation if we
passed
the rescue plan and flooded the country
with
with money that's exactly what's
happening so every single business
person i talk to
regardless of size rapid rampant
inflation
and difficulty in getting people back to
work
uh congresswoman liz cheney ousted from
her gop leadership position in the house
uh
this morning in a move uh pushed by
house leaders was that a good decision
look it's up to the house to make these
kind of decisions
we're moving ahead in the senate
focusing on the current challenges we
have with this new administration
well you know when she survived a
no-confidence vote in february you spoke
out on her behalf you said liz cheney is
a leader
with deep convictions and the courage to
act on them she is an important leader
in our party in our nation
and when we were asked about uh her at
the press conference in kentucky
uh you seem to go out of your way to
avoid kind of expressing that support
again
uh saying 100 of my focus is stopping
this new administration so why the
change
well there's no change i stand by what i
said about liz cheney before i'm a great
admirer of hers but as to who's supposed
to be in the leadership in the house
that's up to house republicans and
entirely our focus
is on dealing with this new
administration
i'm hopeful after today that we may be
able to do some things on a bipartisan
basis
but they got off to a pretty hard
left-wing start
bills like the one we were talking about
earlier that are in the rules committee
there's nothing bipartisan about that
uh this is a 50 50 senate we don't
intend
to participate in turning america into a
left-wing kind of bernie sanders vision
of what this country ought to be like
congresswoman cheney said on the floor
last night we face a threat
america has never seen before a former
president who provoked a violent attack
on the capitol she went on to say in an
effort to steal the election
he's resumed his aggressive effort to
convince americans that the election was
stolen from him
he risks inciting further violence is
there anything that she said that you
disagree with there
i don't know how many times i have to
tell you i'm focusing on dealing with
the conditions we find ourselves in now
with regard to the election
i voted to certify the election
i expressed myself on that issue on
several different occasions several
months ago but now
we're in may and the issue is
what can we agree on to do for the
american people on a bipartisan basis
and i hear you senator and with all due
respect president trump
the former president is not focusing on
those things it doesn't seem he just put
out a statement
on monday claiming that michigan was
stolen and might be
overturned and he continues to kind of
hammer republicans in different ways
and a lot of republicans seem to be
basing their 2022 strategy
on the former president so i guess my
question is
can you move on like you're saying uh
without dealing with the former
president what he puts out day to day
about the election your question is
about what will the 22 elections be
about
if you look at american history the 22
election is very likely to be a
referendum on the performance
of the new administration bill clinton
two years in
lost the house and senate barack obama
lost the house donald trump
lost the house the first off-year
election into a new administration will
be a referendum on the performance of
the biden administration
if this administration continues to
present a program that bernie sanders
loves only bernie sanders could love
this kind of program
that will be what we debate in the fall
of 22.
all right i'm going to try one more time
since april 24th fundraising emails
from republicans have mentioned the
former president 97 times an average of
more than five times a day
you're saying the focus is not on the
past but you're using the former
president's name
and republicans are to raise money for
2022.
well look each individual candidate is
going to use whatever
appeal they think works to try to raise
money yeah
i'm not in the money raising business
i'm in the
senate business and what we're trying to
do here is to make some progress for the
country i have one more thing 15 seconds
how has president biden changed since
you worked with him as vice president
and senator from delaware
i don't think he's changed i i liked
the the president i liked him when he
was in the senate we did some deals
together i never thought he was a
moderate and so i wasn't particularly
surprised
that this administration started off on
the hard left
the way they'll pivot is when they can't
get enough votes to do things
on their own and i think that's what
we're seeing here
with the good session that we had down
at the white house today about an issue
we can tackle on a bipartisan basis
senator mcconnell we're always welcome
back here on special report we
appreciate the time
thank you brett hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else